So welcome to psychology to 30
personality and its transformations.
So I guess the first thing I'll do is
our,
for you,
a bit of a description of what
personality is.
It's a very extensive phenomenon.
Personality.
Your personality determines the way you
perceive.
So what that means,
at least in part,
is that your personality actually
determines
how you're going to extract facts from
the world.
You know,
people think that you see the world and
then you think about it then,
then maybe you react emotionally and
then you act.
But that's really not accurate.
It's too slow,
first of all.
And there's lots of times when you have
to be fast.
And if you had to go through all that
processing before you acted,
you'd be dead.
So personality is deeper than what you
do with facts.
It's deep enough.
So that determines how you bias your
perceptions
so that the world appears to you in a
particular manner.
We don't really understand how
personality does that yet.
MMM.
It determines your emotional response to
things.
People differ in their positive
emotions,
their baseline level of positive emotion
and their variability and they differ in
their negative emotions as well.
So some people are set to be anxious and
some people are set to be fearless and
the environment can move that around to
some degree.
But a fair bit of it's at least it's
origin point seems to be pretty tightly
determined by genetic factors.
So
people differ in the degree to which
they're creative or they differ in the
degree to which they're orderly.
There's all sorts of different phenomena
that are tightly attached to what makes
you different from other people because
that's another way of thinking about
personality,
colors,
your actions because you act in
accordance with your personality,
it's,
it determines your values.
And so that also determines how you act
because of course you act in accordance
with what you value because you're
moving from where you are,
which isn't as as good as it could be to
somewhere better and you have to decide
for yourself.
Or maybe that's decided for you by your
temperament,
just where better is.
And so it's very interesting and
exciting for me to teach personality
because it's,
it's the most personal of all phenomena
and it's,
it's understanding isn't extraordinarily
relevant,
I think to everyone.
Understanding your personality can help
you figure out who you are for better or
for worse.
Because with every set of personnel,
personality attributes there tend to
come on an associated set of devices.
So for example,
if you're an orderly person,
which in many cases is a good thing,
then you're also prone to harsh
judgments.
You tend to be xenophobic and sexual
behaviors that aren't strictly normative
are likely to discuss you.
And you might think of that as something
that you conclude as a consequence of
your experience.
But it looks in many ways like it's
determined before you act.
In some ways,
personality theory can also help you
understand other people because it's
easy to think that other people are like
you and they are like you.
They're like you enough so that more or
less you can communicate with them,
but they're also very different from
you.
And so often when you're communicating
with people,
they're actually starting with a
different set of a priori presumptions
than you are and we'd like to think that
things can be worked out as a
consequence of logical negotiation and
that's true to some degree,
but these a priority factors that
underlie your being itself interfere
with the ability to use logic because
logic is usually predicated on values
and values in turn are predicated on
your temperament.
So having an appreciation for
differences in personality can help you
understand your own personality and
maybe improve it and also understanding
and and give some credence to the
viewpoints of other people.
One of the things we've been studying in
my lab for example,
is the relationship between personality
and political belief.
I know when it's been thought for a long
time,
it's kind of an enlightenment idea that
you come to your political beliefs as a
consequence again of rational
deliberation.
You take a look at the facts,
you analyze them and you extract out
what you think are the appropriate,
what is the appropriate information from
that analysis.
But we've found,
for example,
that people who are high in creativity,
openness,
which is the technical term really for
the trait that's associated with
creativity.
People who are high in openness and low
in conscientiousness,
conscientiousness is basically
industriousness in order to get high in
openness,
low in conscientiousness,
they tend to be liberal or left leaning.
Whereas people who are more
conscientious and less creative tend to
be conservative.
And that seems to be true more or less
cross culturally,
at least in those cultures where the
left right spectrum is similar in nature
to the left right spectrum in North
American culture.
So,
and we also found,
although this,
we're still kind of wrestling with this,
finding that the effects of your
personality on your political preference
and you're voting behavior actually
increase as you get older.
They don't decrease.
So in some sense,
the degree to which your eight by a
state priority,
by your temperamental perspective,
dominates your thoughts and your
behavior even more as you age.
So I don't really know what to make of
that.
You know,
and it's,
it's not the sort of thing that,
that people normally bring into a
political discussion.
But the next time that you're,
most of you are probably left wing
because most of you are open and
intelligent and low in
conscientiousness,
relatively speaking.
And,
uh,
because you're,
you're likely to be lower in orderliness
than the typical population.
Given that you're interested in this
course.
The next time that you're having a
discussion with someone who's
conservative,
you might give some credence to the idea
that you're actually talking to someone
who's quite different than you.
It isn't just that they believe a bunch
of stupid things that you can't
understand why anyone would possibly
believe it's that the facts themselves,
array themselves before those people
differently than they do in front of
you.
And if you listen as they should listen
to you,
then you know,
you might learn something that you
wouldn't know given your temperamental
stance.
So
practical matters.
You need the,
you need to know this url.
Okay?
So you have to write it down because
that's where the syllabus is.
And,
uh,
opposed to copy of it on blackboard as
well.
But for now,
what's there and the syllabus lists
everything that you need to know about
the course.
And I'm going to go through it today,
but it tells you what the lecture topics
are.
Of course the readings are posted there
except for the texts.
There's two books for the class.
There's a textbook and a book called the
Black Swan,
um,
and all the assignments and so forth.
And their requirements are listed on the
syllabus as well.
So it should serve as a place where you
can get all the information you need for
the course.
But we'll walk through it today and I'll
give you an overview of what the course
is going to be like.
So now it didn't just personality that
this course is about,
people tend to think of personality as
something that's relatively fixed and
stable because if it was fluctuating
completely all over the potential range
of personality,
that wouldn't be a lot of utility and
discussing it.
But it is stable so that you are who you
are.
But it's also amenable to change.
Now it's difficult to change your
personality.
It's as if in some sense that the dice
was rolled or five sets of dice.
As it turns out,
we're rolled at the point where you were
born and you were granted a particular
kind of personality configuration on the
off chance that that configuration could
find its proper niche in the
environment.
It's sort of like people have more or
less settled on a five dimensional
personality model,
which we'll talk about a lot in the last
half of the course.
But the idea seems to be that perhaps is
that the environment that you inhabit,
which is largely social,
right?
It's not just physical,
it's mostly social cause you're like
hyper social primates.
Some of you are probably checking your
email right now.
Um,
it's as if there are niches within that
space that may or may not be there may
or may not predominate.
And the dice rolls when you're conceived
and you're given a set of attributes and
with any luck you can find a niche in
the broader social and physical
environment where your particular set of
attributes is going to be functional for
you.
And so a lot of,
and it's,
this is something to think about too.
We'll try to get into this in some depth
in the class.
A lot of what you need to do to make
your life at least tolerable is to
figure out what your personality
attributes are and then to find a niche
where they're valued.
So for example,
for those of you that are creative,
you,
you probably know who you are.
It's actually a rare trait by the way.
Um,
I wouldn't recommend banking or law
because law and banking,
just to take two examples,
are very conservative enterprises.
We tested the hundred most creative
lawyers in Canada at one point with,
they were nominated by their firms.
And the most outstanding personality
attribute of the hundred most creative
Loris was not openness.
It wasn't creativity,
it was conscientiousness,
even though they were the hundred most
creative lawyers.
And of course largely depends on
precedent.
And how creative do you want your lawyer
to be?
You know,
if your lawyer is creative enough then
you'll be in jail.
So that's probably not,
you know,
it's not the greatest idea.
So it's very useful to get a handle on
what your personality is because then
you can take a look at the potential
environments that lie in front of you
and hopefully match yourself to one of
them.
Now that's a tricky business,
you know,
because it isn't necessarily the case
that the niche that you're most suitable
to inhabit is one that's stable or,
or economically viable,
you know?
And so for example,
I think in,
in some ways it's become more difficult,
for example,
to monetize a variety of different
creative production.
So it's harder to monetize music,
for example,
because of course it can be shared for
nothing.
So,
you know,
it's luck of the draw to some degree.
So now the other part of the course is
the transformation element.
Now,
you know,
personality is stable.
So if you test person at one time and
you test the person later,
then there's high correlations between
the two sets of tests.
But there's also variability and the
variability is the part that contains
the potential,
so to speak,
for transformation.
So you're,
uh,
you're an entity with cause I fixed
attributes.
But that doesn't mean that you can't
transform and learn.
You know,
you're a sort of this weird balance
between stability and plasticity,
which actually happened to be two metta
traits of personality.
And I also want to take you through the
process of understanding what
personality transformation is and how to
conceptualize it.
Because personality transformation comes
at a cost and the cost seems to be with
each incremental change,
there is an equal increment of
unstability of instability,
you know,
so that's often because you learn things
painfully,
right?
I mean,
if you learn something,
if it's something you expect and
something you want,
there's no learning there,
generally speaking because you expect it
so it means you already know about it
and you want it.
So it's good.
The most potent learning experiences
tend to occur when something occurs in
within the realm of your experience that
you don't expect and often that you
don't want.
And those are the sorts of things that
destabilize your personality.
Now they can also be the sort of things
that eventually expand it because if you
encounter something that you don't
understand,
that means that there's information in
the event that you haven't incorporated
within your own being.
And if you can do that,
then at least in principle,
then your dominion of competence can
expand.
Now one of the things you'd see the
courses sort of broken up,
roughly speaking,
it's broken up into two sections.
There are more sections which I'll get
into,
but the biggest split is actually
between the clinical theorists.
So those would be people who are,
some of them are psychiatrists,
most of them,
more practitioners.
So their theories were derived from
observations,
mostly of personality pathology and
transformation.
The first half of the course is really
about that.
And that's partly because I think the
the most,
um,
intellectually compelling and,
and,
and perhaps even practically useful
theories of personality have in fact
been derived by clinical practitioners
like Freud and like human,
like Rogers and of the various people
that we're going to talk about him.
Um,
one of the things that's really
interesting about the clinical
practitioners,
because they have to deal with issues of
health,
roughly speaking,
good mental health versus poor mental
health say,
is that they're all their fields of
endeavor also deal with values because
it's almost impossible to grapple with
the problem of the good or wellbeing or
mental health or psychopathology or
suffering or anxiety or pain or any of
those phenomena without also necessarily
evaluating the domain of values.
It's like,
okay,
well you're a certain way.
Do you want to be better?
If you were better,
would that mean that you are more
mentally healthy?
What exactly does better mean and is it
useful to use that sort of descriptive
terminology?
When you're talking about personality
being,
I assume that most of you wanting to be
better people now,
your definition of what might better is
going to differ again,
according to your temperament,
but generally speaking it seems that
people are,
they're like scissor office there uphill
climbers,
you know,
you don't want to go from bad to worse.
You want to go from where you are to
better.
And that means that you have to
conceptualize what constitutes better.
And that makes personality theory at
least in re in regard to its,
its clinical domain,
a very strange hybrid of science and
engineering because you know,
generally science doesn't deal with
values,
but if you're dealing with human
personality,
it seems impossible to avoid the the
topic,
especially if you're concerned with
something like mental health.
So you know,
you can assume that mental health means
normal,
but most of you don't assume that.
Right?
Because you know,
if you're,
if you're actually,
if you want your reach to exceed your
grasp,
a lot of you are going to be aiming for
something that's better than normal or
better than average.
Let's say we don't consider average
optimal.
And that's a strange thing.
So the first half of the course that
deals with the clinicians is going to
take us into the realm of personality
transformation and also necessarily lead
us through a discussion of value because
I can't see that there's any avoiding
it.
Also,
I think it would be ridiculous to avoid
it because why you should do things is,
you know,
how you conceptualize why you should do
things is extraordinarily integral part
of your personality.
I mean,
one of the things that we found
recently,
um,
it's a variant of an exercise that I'm
going to have you do in this class,
um,
is that if you get people to spend a
couple of hours writing down their
vision of the future,
you know,
so the,
the question basically is,
all right,
so imagine yourself now.
Now imagine yourself three to five years
in the future.
Okay,
now and here's the rules.
Imagine that you're trying to take care
of yourself.
Like you would take care of someone that
you cared about.
There's a strange,
it's a strange framing,
but you know,
people often don't take care of
themselves as well as they take care of
other people.
You know,
they're hard on themselves and they
denigrate themselves because you know,
we might be painfully aware of all your
multiple inadequacies.
And of course,
inadequacies are part of the human
condition.
So it's easy if you've become cognizant
of your inadequacies to also denigrate
the value of your being and not take
care of yourself.
And that's not a good thing.
I mean,
flawed is you are.
You're probably no worse than anyone
else.
And if things shouldn't be good for you,
then the logical conclusion is that
things shouldn't be good for anyone else
either.
So,
you know,
start with yourself and assume that you
deserve some,
at least the basic elements of the
attitude that you would give to someone
that you care for.
Okay?
So you put yourself in that mind frame
now you think three to five years down
the road,
what do you want for friendship?
What do you want for career?
What do you want for family?
How do you want your intimate
relationships to be constituted?
What are you going to do when you're not
working?
What sort of productive useful
activities and interesting activities
are you going to engage it?
If you could optimize your life three to
five years down the road,
what exactly would that look like?
All right,
so there's that question.
Then we also get people to do dance or
the reverse question,
which is all right.
Now imagine that you allow your
inadequacies and your pathology such as
they are to gain the upper hand,
which I'm sure they do,
and your own life zone and week to week
basis.
Imagine you really let them get out of
hand.
So you know you're,
you're drinking 26 ounces of vodka every
second day in five years or you know,
you're lying uncontrollably or no one
can stand to you cause you're too
disagreeable in neurotic or whatever
you've,
you know,
whatever your weaknesses happened to be.
Maybe you procrastinate all the time and
end up unemployed.
Imagine three to five years down the
road that things turn out as badly for
you as they can because you've allowed
things to go from bad to worse and
conceptualize that
while.
And then we have people write a plan
based on the positive vision.
The negative vision I think is really
useful because if you're running towards
something,
it's also extremely useful from a
motivational perspective to be running
away from something at the same time,
you know,
then you can harness your positive
emotions which are associated with
approaching a valued goal.
And you can have your negative emotions
like fear chasing you instead of
standing in front of you,
interfering with your progress.
Anyways.
When we have people do this exercise,
their grade point average,
for example,
we'd done this with 3000 people so far,
grade point average goes up about 25%
dropout rate goes down about 30% so you
know,
it seems like the act of positing value,
so like a valued future or or terribly,
you know,
negatively valued future is a
prerequisite to appropriate functional
being.
And so what that means in part is that
human beings are value producing
creatures and there's just no way of,
it's,
it's ridiculous to avoid dealing with
that well in a class on personality
despite the fact that it's and as uneasy
balance between science and engineering,
so to speak.
So that's the first part of the course.
All right,
so let's,
let's get into details here.
Okay.
We're going to tell you a little bit
about this picture.
That's Jonah.
I don't know how many of you know the
story of Jonah,
but the story basically goes like this.
It's an old testament story.
Um,
God tells Jonah to go off and do
something and he doesn't want to do it.
So cause you know,
at least as far as the old testament is
concerned,
God's always telling people to do
horrible and miserable things that are
difficult.
And so avoiding it is the logical thing
to do.
So Jonah goes out on a boat trying to
get away from this demand and there's a
huge storm and you know,
the boat is in danger of being swamped
and um,
the so,
so sailors are all wondering this storm
is happening and Joan and finally admits
that he's,
you know,
got this command from God.
He's running away from it.
So they throw him overboard and then
sees common.
Anyways,
Joan ends up inside this whale and then
later,
three days later,
as it happens,
it's spits them up back on shore.
Now
you might think,
why the hell are you telling us this
story?
But I can give you a hint about why I'm
telling you this story.
Uh,
remember the last time that you broke
through the thin ice that you're skating
on all the time.
You know,
everybody knows what that means,
right?
Is that you're cruising along in your
life perfectly content or at least
reasonably content,
and then something strikes you out of
the blue.
Maybe it's the death of someone that you
love,
or it's the breakup of a relationship or
something that you failed dismally at,
or some manner in which you'd be trade a
friend or they betrayed you and all of a
sudden,
everything that you stand on disappears
and you get swallowed up.
Oh,
it turns out that the Motif of being
swallowed by something that lurks
underneath like the,
like the shark in jaws.
It's a very,
very old story.
In fact,
it's the oldest story that human beings
tell.
It's the same story,
for example,
that you see,
if you watched the hobbit guys,
how many of you have seen the hobbit
recently or the Lord of the Rings?
Yeah,
yeah.
Well,
you know,
in the harbor,
the little hobbit encounters a dragon,
right?
And everyone seems to understand what
that means even though it's completely
absurd proposition.
And that's allied with this sort of,
this sort of pattern of story.
And the idea is something like this is
that
your,
your current pattern of being is
fragile.
And the reason for that is that there's
not very much of you and there's an
awful lot of the world.
And what that means is that at any
moment,
some element of the world that you have
not mastered and do not understand can
emerge and destroy you potentially your
psychological health,
your physical health and your dreams.
And that puts you somewhere.
And the ancients believed that that put
you somewhere that was akin to being
devoured by a great beast.
And if you're lucky,
then you know,
it spits you up later.
If you're unlucky,
then you stay inside it.
And you know,
those are the sorts of people that you
see in mental hospitals are wandering
around on the streets.
You know,
hearing voices and talking to
themselves,
they never get out.
And the standard transformative
narrative is descent an asset.
You learn something by deteriorating
first and then by reascended as you
incorporate it.
And I love the story because,
well,
the first of all to know that story,
which is the fundamental story of
mankind,
to know that story means first of all,
that you understand that there's no
learning without pain and the pain is a
necessary prerequisite to
transformation.
Now the pain doesn't necessarily have to
be of the sort that completely destroys
you.
But generally a valuable lesson is one
that's difficult to learn.
And what that also means something very
interesting about the human psyche
because,
and this is something to really think
about too,
you know,
cause you might say,
are you who you are
or are you who you could be or are you
the thing that changes from who you are
to what you could be?
And
which of those things you identify with
makes a huge difference to your life.
So for example,
if you are who you are,
then you can't talk to someone who
doesn't agree with you.
You can't listen to them because they
may tell you something that you don't
already know and that'll change you.
And if you are who you are and that's
the right way to be,
then you don't want to be changed.
And if you are who you're going to be in
the future,
then if any circumstance comes along to
destabilize the environment so that that
future becomes unlikely,
then you're in the same boat.
Things are going to fall apart around
you.
But if you're the thing that can change
when change is necessary,
well then you don't have to be who you
are or who you could be.
You can be the thing that changes.
And then when new things come along,
regardless of how they're presented to
you,
well then you can welcome them even
though they're going to destabilize you
in the hope that what comes out the next
what comes out the other side will be an
improved version of you.
One of the things that all talk to you
about,
especially in the first couple of
lectures is the notion that the idea
that you should identify with the part
of your psyche that can transform is
actually one of the world's most
fundamental religious ideas and the
reason I'm discussing religious ideas
with you in part is Walt's.
Partly because when we deal with some of
the more profound thinkers in the early
part of the chorus and the part that
deals with psychoanalysis like young for
example being use depth psychology goes
down deep enough into the psyche so that
the appropriate language to describe the
phenomena that he is dealing with is
always religious language is young sort
of conceptualized religious language,
religious symbols as the grammatical,
as part of the grammatical structure of
the psyche.
So that's an archetype by the way,
that's what an archetype is.
An archetype is,
is part of the structure of the psyche.
It's,
it's something you can't escape from.
So I could give you,
I'll give you a quick example of that.
So,
um,
men are much more visually oriented
towards sexual stimuli than women.
It appears that way.
Women seem to be more oriented towards
auditory sexual stimuli.
So for example,
there was a book published a little
while ago called dataclysm.
It's,
it's the first third of,
it's quite interesting.
It,
it's written by one of the Google
analytics guys and it's,
sorry,
I'm sorry I'm wrong.
It's called a billion wicked thoughts.
I read too,
that we're dealing with Internet
phenomena is called a billion wicked
thoughts.
And,
uh,
the authors were analyzing,
pornography usage on the web.
And you know,
of course,
for the longest time,
about 35% of web traffic was pornography
and it actually really got the web
going,
weirdly enough.
Men.
Yeah,
it's strange,
you know,
and so that sexual motivation was what
drove to technological innovation.
It's interesting.
Even now,
you know,
one of the things that's driving
computer chip technology is the
necessity for making more and more
accurate,
um,
CGI movies.
So it's very strange things often that
motivate human progress,
right?
On the one hand,
it's the desire for entertainment more
and more realistic artificial
entertainment.
On the other hand,
it's sex,
which is exactly what Freud would
presume anyways,
man,
look at visual stimuli and women read
pornography.
So now with regards to men,
there some things you can say about what
men find attractive sexually if they're,
if they're heterosexual.
So for example,
they prefer a west waist to hip ratio of
about 0.68 and that's standard across
body types.
So a thin woman who has a hip waist to
hip ratio of 0.68 is attractive and uh,
you know,
a mesomorphic woman,
woman of medium build with a waist to
hip ratio of 0.68 is also attractive.
And that's in some sense,
that's the function of the archetype.
And that archetype would be the
archetype of air oss or Venus or,
or beauty.
And if the problem with those archetypes
in some sense,
and this is what makes the market
tipple,
is you can't argue yourself out of them.
They're in built.
They're like,
they're part of your operating system to
use a terrible analogy.
So anyways,
he owns,
his claim was that the architectural
images are religious fundamentally that
they hit you with the force of
religious,
uh,
what's the word?
Re revelation.
So,
so that's all in that picture.
Say,
you know,
a picture's worth a thousand words and
that one's worth a lot more than a
thousand.
You know,
you also might ask yourself,
you know,
why don't people do what's right?
It's a good question because
hypothetically they could,
and the answer seems to be something
like,
well,
transforming yourself into something
that's continually better means
continually being swallowed up by
something like this.
And so it's hard and frightening.
So that's why people aren't enlightened
and there's gotta be some reason given
that it's hypothetically possible.
You know,
when you hear people like Joseph
Campbell say things like,
follow your bliss,
you know,
and so that sounds pretty easy.
You want to develop your personality,
just do what you love.
You know it's a corruption of Carl
Jung's thinking because young would say,
well,
follow what you're interested.
It'll take you somewhere you really
don't want to go.
And then maybe you learn something.
So,
and that's a whole different,
that's a whole different proposition.
So,
okay,
I already asked you to write down the
website.
So it's easy to find.
You just have to type my name into the
web and my website will come up and then
you can find the course.
But I would still write it down.
I'll show it to you again at the end of
class for those who didn't,
who didn't get it.
All right.
So
here's the basic,
here's what we're going to try to do
during this semester.
In some sense,
this is,
I've tried to structure this class in
some sense,
both sort of historically and
developmentally.
So the first thing that I want to
describe to you is an elaborated version
of what I just did when I was telling
you about the Jonah image.
I want to talk to you about an array of
what you might describe as eternal
images there or they're like eternal
characters in a story that our
architectural,
and I want to show you how those have
been represented by cultures that we
would regard as say pre-scientific.
I think that's a good way to think about
them.
So those are cultures that haven't
precisely divided the world up into
objective reality and subjective
experience.
And there's a,
there seems to be something like a set
of constant reference that human beings
have used all over the world to orient
themselves in their existence.
And so I want to talk to you about those
because I think one of the things that
does is that it provides you with an
underlying theory metatheory it's a
better way of of thinking about it,
a metatheory into which you can plug all
the particular theories that we're going
to talk about.
You know,
because one of the strange things about
personality theory is that it's not
exactly integrated.
There's an,
I suppose that's also partly because
it's still a pre science in some ways.
So there are a variety of different
theories and all of the theories have
somewhat different claims and all of the
claims seem logically coherent,
appropriate and applicable,
but they don't necessarily seem mutually
inclusive.
So thinker a might claim one thing and
think you're be another and the two
things aren't.
They can't logically coexist.
And so that makes learning about
personality theory difficult because
things that aren't coherent across any
distance of any length of time or
difficult to remember.
So anyways,
I'm going to provide you with an
underlying metatheory and then we're
going to try to plug all the different
theorists into that metatheory and then
hopefully that'll give you a nice
coherent and memorable account of
personality and its transformations.
So that's mythological representations.
I'm going to show you how the
personality has been represented since
history began,
literally since history began because
the oldest written documents that we
have are about personality and its
transformations.
So,
and interestingly enough,
those tell a story that you're all
entirely familiar with and that you've
seen hundreds of times as you've grown
up.
They're constantly represented in movies
and in tv shows and everything that you
would regard as an infj brawling
narrative.
Because one of the things you might ask
yourself is,
why the hell are you interested in
stories?
You know,
why are you interested in watching TV?
Why are you interested in going to
movies?
You know,
you'll line up and pay for them.
It's very strange behavior.
And you often see in movies things that
are completely impossible and yet you
swallow them without a second's thought.
It's,
you know,
as long as they're done in a reasonable
manner that allow you to,
in some sense to suspend disbelief.
You get completely engaged.
And a lot of the early theorists,
the ones that we're going to talk about,
especially with regards to depth
psychology,
posited that the human personality was
in fact a narrative or even even more
deeply that human experience,
which you could think of as existence
itself has a narrative structure.
Now that's a pretty broad claim,
but you know,
there's been some pretty,
there's been some heavyweight
philosophers who've wandered down that
road.
So heidegger,
for example,
is one of them.
So,
and that's very,
that's a very interesting thing to
consider because it's certainly the case
that human beings,
if you talk about a human being,
you tend to use something that's like a
story.
And when you recount your own being,
you tend to use something like a story.
And that sort of begs the question,
you know,
does that mean in fact that your
experience is either a story or
something like a story?
One of the things young said I really
like this is you should figure out which
story you're living because you're
living a story and it might be a
tragedy.
And so you know,
you want to find out because if it's a
tragedy you don't come to a very good
end.
Another thing young said was this is
also worth thinking about.
People don't have ideas,
ideas have people.
And so what we are dealing with say is
that if you're living out of tragedy,
the tragedy has you,
you don't have it.
And if you can figure out what the
tragedy is that has you in its grip,
then you have a fighting chance of
escaping from it into a more pleasing
plot.
But it's no easy thing,
you know?
So if you're one of those people to whom
the same terrible thing keeps happening
over and over after the third time,
approximately,
you might ask yourself,
you know,
is this the world or is this me?
All right.
So we,
we moved from mythological
representations into a discussion of
both heroic and shamanic initiations.
And the reason we're going to talk about
shamonic initiations is,
first of all,
they are a logical,
there are logical next step in moving
from the fundamental mythology into
depth psychology.
But also because initiation processes
are processes that archaic people have
used learning to use to catalyze
personality transformation.
So for example,
a typical initiation tends to be more
young men who are initiated more often
than young women.
And the hypothesis there is that mother
nature initiates young women all on her
own.
Whereas with young men,
something has to be imposed from a
cultural perspective in order to
catalyze their transition from childhood
dependency and make them independent
adults.
And that usually involves some
relatively terrible experience that I
think it does.
Two things.
One is it helps the person defined what
actually constitutes terrible.
Cause you might ask yourself,
you know,
how worried should you be about
something?
You know,
let's say you wake up in the morning and
you know you've,
you've got a wide,
I know you've got an ache in your side.
It's like,
okay,
it wasn't there the night before.
So what does that mean?
Well,
you pulled a muscle or you're going to
die of cancer in three months.
It's like you don't know.
So how upset should you be?
Well,
the answer is you don't know.
And I think one of the things that
initiation process is due to people is,
um,
calibrate their anxiety systems.
So you know,
unless you've been required at some
point in your existence to face
something that is truly awful without
destroying you,
maybe you don't know how to calibrate
what you should be worried about and
what you shouldn't.
And it seems to be the implicit theory
upon which initiation rituals are
predicated.
You know,
and they,
they tend to reemerge spontaneously.
You know,
you see them reemerge,
for example,
in situations like fraternity hazing,
you know,
or medical residency for that matter.
Because if you're going to be a medical
resident,
you can be completely assured that
you're going to be tortured to death for
two years.
So,
and when you come out of that,
you won't be the same person that you
were when you went in.
And it isn't necessarily the case that
that will be that you'll be better.
But that's a different issue.
So I want to talk about the structure of
shamonic and heroic initiations,
partly to further our understanding of
personality transformation,
but also partly to give you an idea of
the body of
the relationship between the symbolic
realm and the,
and the day to day realm prior to the
emergence of psycho analysis.
Because when psychoanalysis emerged in
the first part of the 20th century,
the psychoanalysts,
mostly Freud,
and you discovered what you might regard
as a symbolic realm they associated it
with,
with within.
So the symbolic realm in terms of your
experience might be what you dream at
night.
You know,
how bizarre dreams are.
when there's debate about whether
they're interpretable,
say some people's dreams are
interpretable and some people's aren't
in my experience.
But it's,
uh,
the dream realm,
for example,
is very peculiar because obviously you
experience it,
it's quasi coherent in that when you
wake up and you remember it,
you can,
you can remember it.
First of all,
it's not random.
It's not like white noise on a blank
screen.
You know,
it's,
it has characters,
they're doing things.
Um,
although there are,
you know,
there are dynamic jumps usually in the
narrative structure that make it
difficult to understand.
There are chunks of it that are clearly
comprehensible and that seemed to have
the same quality.
Roughly speaking is something cinematic.
Um,
things transform in peculiar ways in
dreams.
The normal laws of physics are often
suspended in one way or another.
So people frequently dream of flying,
for example.
Um,
and most peculiarly dreams seem to
happen to you,
you know,
because you say,
well,
I drank last night,
but that doesn't generally mean that,
you know,
you decided which movie to play in your
head so to speak.
It seems when you're dreaming that
things happen to you,
you're in your dream that are like the
things that happened to you in regular
life in that they happen.
You don't make them happen.
So in a dream,
you're the subject of uncontrollable
forces in some sense,
just as you are in waking life.
It's like,
okay,
well who in the world is dreaming?
You know,
it's not the ego obviously cause he
can't control it unless you happen to be
a lucid dreamer.
You know,
some people can become conscious during
their dreams and exercise a certain
degree of control over the contents.
Although it's a relatively,
it's a relatively undeveloped skill.
It's not particularly rare.
How many of you have had lucid dreams?
Yeah,
it's very much,
much more common among women generally
for reasons we don't really understand
so,
but most of the time a dream is
something in which you're embedded.
It's like what's dreaming exactly.
You know,
you would say,
well the world is dreaming inside of
you.
It's nature dreaming inside of you.
It's a natural phenomena and it has the
same kind of meaning that any other
natural phenomena has,
which is what meaning that you can
discover that turns out to be useful.
So there's a relationship between that
internal set of processes,
you know,
that deeply symbolic set of processes
and the kinds of rituals and symbols
that are used in archaic ceremonies like
heroic in Shamanic initiations.
And so that's partly why I wanted to
tell you about them.
I'd also helps you understand,
I think a little more deeply
the price that you have to pay in order
for transfer in order to transform.
Because the rule in most archaic
cultures is that to transform a male
adolescent into a man requires
dismantling the childhood personality
often rather brutally,
and replacing it with something that's
new.
And so,
you know,
you might think,
well perhaps the brutality isn't
necessary,
but,
um,
it's hard to say what's necessary.
You know,
there's a rule in,
in psychological therapy and the rule is
if you want to improve,
you have to identify what it is that
you're afraid of that stopping you.
And then you have to confront it.
And you have to do that voluntarily.
It's the primary rule.
You might say it's primary rule of
psychotherapy.
You're going somewhere there,
impediments,
the impediments make you afraid because
you're afraid you start progressing.
So what do you have to do?
You have to face the things that are
stopping you voluntarily,
you know?
And that's part of the heroic,
that's actually part of standard hero
narratives,
which is face the thing that you're
afraid of.
And that's why,
for example,
in the Hobbit,
Frodo,
Frodo is not bill bose.
The second one.
Yeah.
Frodo has to face the dragon and the
dragon hordes gold.
Billable.
Sorry.
Well thank you.
Yes,
that is what I was asking.
Bilbo has to face the dragon and the
dragon hordes gold.
It's like what the hell does a giant
reptile need with gold?
Well,
the answer to that in part is that the,
the giant reptile represents that which
you are afraid of.
And the treasure that it sits on
represents what you gain if you conquer
what you're afraid of.
And it's an architectural story in some
sense because you can't invent a more
frightening story than that more
frightening.
And Richard Story,
there's nothing more frightening than a
dragon,
roughly speaking.
And there's nothing more valuable than a
hoard of gold.
And that's partly what makes the story
archetipal right?
It's taken the phenomena and extended
them to the point of,
of maximum return in some sense.
So
constructivism as piaget mostly,
and a
PSA called himself a genetic
epistemologist,
which is hardly the same thing as a
psychologist.
But Piaget was actually interested this,
and this is something you won't hear in
most classes about piaget.
When Piaget was a adolescent,
he was very obsessed by the growing
split between religion and science.
In fact,
he wrote a novel about that and uh,
he took it upon himself.
His life's goal was to reconcile the gap
between religion and science.
So there's something you don't know.
Did anybody know that about piaget?
How many people know you knew that?
How did you learn that?
Huh?
Wow,
that's,
that's a good way of learning things.
So how many of you knew who knew who
piaget is?
Oh,
that's good.
How many don't you?
It's okay if you don't.
You're probably engineers or some damn
thing.
So
yeah.
Anyways,
Piaget became interested in how
knowledge is developed and he started
with the infant and he's very interested
in how the infant who is an embodied
creature,
you know,
who has a body,
which turns out to be very important if
you want to have a psyche,
how the infant comes to construct his
world.
And I really liked the PSG and approach
because it melds nicely with our
discussion of both personality,
the stable elements of personality and
the transformative elements of
personality.
So,
you know,
cause piaget has a stage theory of
development and um,
he doesn't concentrate a tremendous
amount on the intervening period of
chaos between the stages of development.
But,
um,
but,
but the idea is still there.
So as it is,
say in a Thomas Kuhn's work on the
history of science,
which piaget was aware of [inaudible]
from.
So I want to lay out the Piagetian
theory because
one of the things that piaget was really
good at was understanding that the
psyche is not like a floating soul.
And you know,
people,
we believe perhaps that we've dispensed
with most of the religious
presuppositions that interfere with our
scientific clarity,
which we certainly haven't.
But one idea that's,
that lurks deeply,
it's very difficult to abandoned for a
variety of reasons is the idea that,
you know,
you have a consciousness that sort of
like a soul that sort of stuck in your
body.
You know,
and that's sort of,
you might think about that as your ego
or you might think about it as the I
that you experienced when you talk about
yourself it's like a floating
consciousness,
you know,
and that that's,
that's led people like artificial
intelligence researchers for the longest
time to imagine that they could embody a
mind inside complicated machines and in
that would function perhaps in the same
way that your mind functions.
Piaget is a really good antidote to that
because what piaget points out very
clearly is that you cannot have a mind
like we have without having the body to
begin with.
And so the one of the ways that you can
conceptualize that cause it's very
important is that your personality is
actually oriented towards action rather
than perception of the object of worlds.
Like what the hell do you care about the
objective world?
We didn't even discover it until 500
years ago.
You know,
in,
in a sense,
what you're concerned about is how to
act in the world and your conceptions,
although you may think about them as
conceptions of the objective world,
that isn't what they are,
what they are instead is abstractions of
how to act in the world.
And Piaget explains this in a beautiful
way because he starts with the infant
and he talks about how the infant's body
develops in sync with its psyche and how
the two things are like absolutely
integrally interlock.
And it's a lovely idea.
And I,
I think not only do I think it's right,
I think that all the evidence in the
last 30 years points towards being
right.
You know,
we haven't been able to make artificial
intelligence without embodying the
intelligence in something that acts.
So for example,
the Google cars or they're getting
pretty damn smart,
but they have a body.
Fundamentally,
there are things that can act in the
world,
you know,
and it turns out to be more difficult to
walk than it does to calculate,
you know,
extremely complex mathematical formula,
which a computer can do.
And you know,
a billionth of a second,
even though we haven't got computers
that can walk around in the real world,
that turns out to be difficult.
So Piaget tells you how to build a
psyche from the bottom up and it's,
it's uh,
it's,
it's a prerequisite I think for accurate
understanding of the sorts of things
that we're going to discuss as we
progress.
Then we turned to the depth psychologist
and
people usually start talking about depth
psychology,
psychoanalysis with Freud,
and then move to young saying perhaps
Adler as
yeah,
accomplices or no,
that's not the right word.
Um,
apprentices of Freud.
And I think that's probably because the
Freud,
Ian's got a hold of the,
had the best biographies written first,
but you was influenced by Freud,
but he was equally influenced by nature
and it in fact,
umes primary concerns were associated
with niches,
primary concern and niches.
Primary concern was that God had died in
the late 1900.
So Nietzsche,
the philosopher announced that it's a
famous announcement.
God is dead.
Sometimes you see that written on
bathroom walls.
God is dead.
Nietzsche.
Nietzsche is dead.
God,
what needs you was,
was,
was observing was that,
and this is something you all know
implicitly,
is that the body of knowledge that human
beings had evolved over centuries that
was encapsulated within religious
thinking,
had emerged in conflict with the body of
knowledge that was produced primarily in
Europe over about a 400 year period
ending say it in the beginning of the
20th century.
And the two forms of knowledge seemed
incommensurate the claims of religion
and the claims of science did not seem
to be mutually harmonious.
And the consequence of that,
as far as Nisha was concerned,
was that the religious substructure upon
which at that point Western civilization
was built,
was
rendered invalid.
And the problem with that from a
Nietzschean perspective was while there
were two problems,
one was,
okay,
then what the hell are we doing and why?
And the second was so that's a
nihilistic problem,
right?
If there's no ultimate meaning,
then why do anything?
Just perfectly reasonable question.
And then the second problem was,
well,
in the absence of comprehensive systems
of meaning,
if you don't want to be nihilistic,
what do you do?
And each,
his answer was,
well,
you developed totalitarian systems to
replace religion,
which is exactly what happened in the
20th century,
and that didn't seem to be a very good
solution and we're certainly not done
with that problem yet.
So that's the central problem that needs
your post was like,
we had these evolved systems of meaning
and science undercut them or apparently
undercut them,
and that left people technologically
enlightened,
but spiritually deprived.
And that state of spiritual deprivation,
given that your primary orientation in
the world is towards action,
is equivalent to a mass mental disease.
And it manifests itself in nihilism or
in the pension for adopting totalitarian
belief systems.
It's a big problem.
It killed millions of people in the 20th
century.
You know,
it's not usually regarded as a form of
personality pathology,
but that's just because people don't
think about it properly.
I think now,
une was very interested in that problem.
And so
as a student of nature and which he was,
he wrote,
for example,
there's a series of lectures that were
published,
uh,
as,
as adjuncts to use,
collected word works that I believe are
2,600 pages long and they're written in
very little tight and all they are
commentaries on the first third of a
book called [inaudible],
which is a very short book of very
bizarre because I poetry and it happens
to be the book in which Nietzsche had
his character announced the death of
God.
So young was a real nietzschean scholar.
So what yoga was doing,
see who thought that basically that as
we d animated the cosmos,
so to speak,
you know,
as as the projections of Daddy's that
human beings had created,
had been pulled in from the objective
world,
they didn't disappear.
They weren't destroyed,
as,
as Nietzsche might've presumed,
they sort of went into hiding inside the
psyche,
which is where the era where they
originated from to begin with.
They originated in the imagination.
Now,
a standard objective scientist would
say,
well,
if they originated in the imagination,
they aren't real.
Whereas young would say,
don't kid yourself,
the imagination is real.
It's just a different category of real
and that you better learn how to deal
with it.
Because whether you know it or not,
you are pawns of your imagination in the
same way that the Greeks considered them
pawns of the themselves,
pawns of the Greek gods.
And so that's a hell of a thing to
realize.
You know,
and it's one of the remarkable things
about depth psychology because the
depths psychologists tell you flat out
you are a house of many spirits and one
of them is you.
And if you think that you are the most
powerful spirit in your house of
spirits,
all that means is that you're hyper
protected and diluted because you're
not.
There are things that are deep inside
you and you can think of them as systems
if you want,
which also manifest themselves in,
in psychological phenomena that have
more power than you do.
It's like try not to make a fool of
yourself when you're,
you know,
hopelessly in love with someone you
don't even know.
It's like good luck to that cause you
won't manage it.
And that's because the instinct that
grips you when you're overwhelmingly
attracted to someone is more powerful
than you are and you do what it wants.
Even though you might want to fight
back,
you do what it wants and their reasons
for that.
You know some of them you can think of
them as instinctual reasons.
See if you know,
if you're not overwhelmingly attracted
to someone,
at least throughout most of the history
of mankind,
the probability was pretty low that you
going to initiate any sort of sexual
contact with them.
So when see it,
since that's necessary for the human
race to propagate,
it serves biological purposes to have
you play the role of actor of the
demands of the instinct of reproduction,
which is of course also Freud's main
claim,
right?
Because Freud,
who I place after his fundamental claim
was that the god that reels humanity is,
is air oss,
is set,
sexuality,
you know,
and I'm always,
he also,
he'll introduced an idea called the
death instinct later.
Freud was also concerned about
aggression.
But you know,
in some sense you could say that Freud
believed that we were ruled by two gods,
the god of the goddess of sex,
we'll say,
and the god of war.
And you know,
as,
as far as reductive theories go,
yeah.
Beats most of the claims of postmodern
scholars.
So,
all right,
so that's all pretty fun.
You know,
Freud,
Freud's really,
uh,
in some sense he's in 19th century
atheistic thinker.
He's kind of like Dawkins and the other,
you know,
modern atheist in that ways.
Um,
in some sense a strict darwinist
antibiological reductionist and,
but Freud had some very interesting
things to say.
And one of them I really like,
I mean,
I think Freud had it absolutely dead on
here.
It's like,
one of the things I've noticed in my
clinical practice,
because I'm a,
I'm a clinical psychologist,
is that I never have clients whose
parents made them too independent.
I always have the reverse.
Not,
not that all my clients have this
particular problem,
but the fundamental problem is they
cannot get away from their family.
They've been infant dialyzed or more
accurately,
their families have conspired to have
them remain in an infant dialyzed state.
And so their world is the family.
They can't get out of the world of the
family.
And so in some sense that's still
childhood or adolescence because they're
not dealing with the,
you know,
the concern to the broader world.
And so that's the analysis of that was
done by Freud most particularly in his
conceptualization of the oedipal
complex.
Now Freud concretize that in a variety
of ways that I don't think were
particularly helpful,
but he had his finger on the right
button.
You know,
human are unbelievably dependent when
they're born.
So a mammal of our size should have a
gestation period of two years,
you know,
if,
if we were comparable to other mammals
of approximately our size being pregnant
for two years,
that does not sound like fun.
But you know,
if you,
if you look at animals,
say like,
like,
uh,
like a deer or moose or animals like
that,
pretty much as soon as they're born they
can get up and walk.
Whereas a human being,
it's like 15 months,
right?
It's calling around like,
you know,
little
helpless little thing.
I can't even stand up for 15 months.
Well that's because it's born in some
sense in fetal form.
And so that makes it incredibly deep.
It's kind of like a baby kangaroo except
it's more developed in that,
um,
it makes it incredibly dependent in a
way that no other animal is.
And then of course it takes you,
well let's see,
about 40%,
50% of people your age live in their
parents' houses,
you know,
so you're 20 or 21 or 19 or whatever you
are.
It's like,
you know,
you're still dependent fundamentally.
And so it's not that easy to break a
dependence habit of 19 years.
And you know,
your parents may foster your
independence and chase you the hell out
of the house if they can try to make you
into a functional try to help you become
a functional and independent adult.
But maybe not too.
And it's the,
maybe not,
that's the big problem because it's
actually rather frightening to develop
independence.
Even though you get to be independent,
which is supposed to be the payoff.
And it's easy for that process to be
interfered with.
And one of the things that can really
interfere with it as maternal anxiety.
Now paternal anxiety can interfere with
it too,
but fathers tend to be substantially
less anxious than mothers.
And so the classic Eda pulled mother is
anxious.
And so every time the child tries to do
something that's independent,
her anxiety gets in the way.
Oh,
you better be careful if you're going to
do that.
It's like you hear that 5,000 times,
man,
you're not going to be able to take a
step without,
you know,
without manifesting the anxiety that
you've been taught by a powerful
external force.
That's the oedipal complex in a
nutshell,
fundamentally.
So that's a great thing to,
to figure out.
And we'll look,
I think we're going to look at a movie
called Crumb,
which was,
um,
it's about this
underground cartoonist named our crump.
And uh,
it has some very interesting things to
say about the oedipal complex.
So,
all right,
so
humanism,
existentialism and phenomenology,
narcotic clump together,
brilliant theorists.
I think a lot of this came out in the
1950s.
You went it was,
well,
you could think about it in some sense
as the precursor deposit of psychology.
Except that,
huh?
Except that positive psychology has no
either in psychology or philosophy.
Whereas existentialism has good
grounding in both and it's not naive.
You know,
the existentialists believed that,
well,
the a clump them together for the
purpose of this brief exposition.
The first thing that this group of
thinkers asks you to consider,
this is a hard thing to do,
but if you can do it,
it's really worthwhile is forget about
your normal conceptions,
your formal conceptions of what
constitutes reality and play this game
in stat.
It's like it's,
it's an axiom shift.
Instead of thinking that reality is the
objective world and you're like a
superfluous subjective observer,
a transient subjective observer.
Imagine that what reality is is what you
experience.
That's it.
So everything you experience is equally
real.
Although there are different categories
of real,
right?
I mean,
a dream is not in the same category as
the chair that you're sitting on,
but from the phenomenological point of
view,
a dream and an emotion is just as real a
phenomena as the chair is real.
Okay?
So that's the first accidents.
It's,
it's,
it's the game is sort of what,
what if we,
what if we make that assumption?
So you make that assumption.
The next issue is
what are the essential qualities of what
you experience?
And that can be addressed in a variety
of ways.
One of the most important things that
the existentialists are concerned about
is fundamental anxiety.
So the this group of thinkers would say,
well,
you're,
you have you,
you exist within this domain of
experience.
And one of the phenomena that's most
manifest within that domain is the
feeling of anxiety or dread.
That's a Kierkegaardian idea.
It's that as at in an experience
constituted like yours,
which is somewhat fragile,
which knows its limits,
it's localized in time and space,
the fundamental,
the fundamental negative meaning in some
senses,
anxiety and dread.
And then the question is,
given that that's the fundamental
reality,
what do you do about it?
And so the existentialist id and sense
is
observe your existence.
Find those elements of being that
support you and pursue them.
And that will counterbalance the primary
feeling of dread and alienation and
anxiety and allow you to exist in a
manner that makes existence at least
bearable.
So if you look at the Floridians,
for example,
Verdean sorta think that if there's
something wrong with you,
there's a reason.
So if,
if you were just a normal person,
you'd be okay.
And since you're not a normal person,
something went wrong.
Where's the existentialists take the
opposite idea?
They say,
look,
you're screwed from day one.
That's just how it is.
Because like,
look at you.
You're,
you're flawed,
are finite and there's a thousand
things,
a million things that you don't know
and,
and all sorts of things that are
conspiring to do you in.
It's like with a problem like that,
you don't need more problems to be
unstable.
You're just unstable to begin with.
So they think conceive of negative
emotion related pathology as an integral
part of being and then the question is,
okay,
given that it's like the Buddhist idea
that life is suffering.
It's the same idea.
It's like don't be wondering why your
pathological,
it's so obvious why your pathological,
how could you help but be pathological?
The question is given that what should
you do about it or even is there
anything you can do about it and that's
the question that we'll try to unfold in
this section of the course.
Now the other thing that's really
interesting about this group of thinkers
I think is that especially the later
ones like,
well,
I include Solzhenitsyn has a personality
theorist for for reasons that I won't
talk to you about now.
Solzhenitsyn was a Russian author and he
wrote a book called the Gulag
Archipelago,
which was published in the 1970s and it
was one of the things that knocked over
the Soviet Union because it revealed for
the first time just how corrupt and
murderous the Soviet system was.
Now,
the thing that's interesting about
Solzhenitsyn and also about frankl,
Viktor Frankl,
who was a psychiatrist who had been put
in the Nazi death camps,
is that they were very integrity,
concerned with the idea of the intrinsic
meaning,
fullness and meaninglessness of human
life.
One thing.
So that's the person,
that element.
But the second thing they were concerned
about,
and this sort of made them logical
followers of Nietzsche,
was what effect is your decision about
the meaning of your life have on the
broader social community?
So let's say that your nihilistic or
you're a totalitarian.
So what does that mean?
Like you're not an isolated unit.
You're interacting with people all the
time.
You have a tremendous network of
connections.
You know,
you can think of it this way.
You know a thousand people,
each of those thousand people knows a
thousand people.
That means you're one person from
1,000,002 from a billion.
So instead of being some little
localized.in an random array of dots,
7 billion of them,
you're the center of a connected
network.
And so if there's something that's gone
astray with your psychic functioning,
your psychological functioning,
what exactly does that do to the broader
social community and soldier Nixon's
idea and Frankel's as well?
It's quite straight forward.
It's the two.
The reason that societies become
pathological,
deeply murderously pathological is
because individuals within this society
have become deeply and murderously
pathological.
So instead of society in which is
something that the Marxists would think,
for example,
you know that you're the of social
forces,
the existentialists would say,
ah,
don't be so sure about that.
It's the quality of the individual
decisions that you make on a personal
level,
day to day that spread out into the
broader community and either improve it
or pathologize it.
And so I'm gonna have you read both
frank align solution medicine because I
think they make viciously powerful
arguments that that is in fact the case.
And it's actually quite a useful,
it's a funny thing because often this is
sort of associated with the idea of
facing dragons.
Often you learn the things that are most
vital to your being by considering the
worst possible phenomena.
So I might say,
well,
just think about this.
It's like the idea that frankl and
Solzhenitsyn and others by the way have
been propagating is that whatever
decisions you make that are moral on a
day to day basis aren't isolated to you.
They spread out into the community very
rapidly and so the fate of the community
is dependent in some sense on your
personal morality.
So then,
well that's a terrible thing.
I mean it's a terrible weight,
but it certainly provides an answer to,
well,
why should I do what I do?
It's like,
do good things,
great.
They propagate,
do bad things,
fine.
They propagate to,
and one of the really interesting things
about the existentialist is they took a
look at what happened in the 20th
century with its ungodly murderous
political systems and said,
all right,
just exactly what responsibility does
the individual bear for bringing those
conditions about?
It's like it's a question.
Well,
we're thinking about and it certainly
hasn't lost its relevance.
In fact,
I think it's,
well,
it's as relevant as ever,
so that's great.
That's,
that's really an interesting thing to
do.
Then we move into the fields that are
more strictly scientific,
but a lot of what we've covered in the
beginning of the class provides the
platform for that.
I'm going to tell you about the
structure and function of the basic
biological systems that underlie your
motivations and your emotions.
And roughly speaking,
we're going to say that a motivational
system sets a goal for you.
So if you're hungry,
you're goal is to eat.
Obviously if you're thirsty,
you're goal is to consume some liquid
goal setting systems,
and there's a system for each of those.
We'll call them drives.
Even though that's we'll call the
motivational systems because they're not
really drives where his emotions are,
things that are more likely to manifest
themselves as markers for your position
on the way to the goal.
So for example,
if you have a goal in mind and you're
progressing towards it without any
obstacles,
you're going to feel positive emotions.
And if you have a goal in mind and
you're progressing towards it and you
encounter obstacles,
then you're going to experience negative
emotions.
And what I want to do is outline what I
think is the best relatively current
neuroscience on the structure and
function of those systems.
And what we'll see is that there's a
nice analog,
the peer Jedi and story about how the
psyche develops and the way the brain is
organized.
And there's a nice analog between the
theories of psychological symbolism that
were pursued by the depths psychologists
and the relationship between the brain
areas that subsume your sense of
individuality and the underlying
motivational and emotional systems that
guide and drive and constrained and
allow your behavior.
So,
so that'll put some biology underneath
the theorizing and I think that's a
really,
that's also a very fun thing to have
happen.
Then after that we're going to talk
about five factor trait theory and fight
the five factor trait theory is the most
modern formulation of psychometric
theory and psychometric theory is the
statistical reduction of dis data sets
that describe human personality.
It's,
it's the,
so if I,
if I took an infinite bank of questions
that I could ask you about your
personality and then I subjected them to
the proper kind of statistical analysis,
I could group those questions into
coherent groups.
And what I would discover is that your
personality has something resembling a
five factor structure,
five dimensions.
It's a lot of dimensions.
The world has four dimensions,
right?
Your personality has five,
so that's plenty complicated and we're
going to walk through what those
dimensions are,
what the variability represents,
how they might be related to the
motivational systems and the thought
patterns that we discovered earlier.
And then all the practical consequences
of knowing about those systems.
And we actually,
the model I'm going to present you with
this tiered,
so the top level is stability and
plasticity.
The next tier is the standard five
factor model,
extroversion and openness that makes up
plasticity,
agreeableness,
conscientiousness,
and
what's the other one there?
What's that?
No,
no.
Yes.
Neuroticism.
I'm sorry.
Emotional stability reversed.
Yeah.
So,
and then underneath that,
each of those breaks into two.
And so I want to describe to you the
most current research on what each of
those hierarchical tiers mean and why
you want to know that.
And at the same time I'm going to have
you do a personality analysis online.
So what it will do is help you identify
your personality virtues using a big
five model and your personality faults
also using a big five months.
So that'll give you some insight into
who you are and what the Hell's wrong
with you and also what's good about you
at the same time that we're trying to
elaborate these dimensions on a,
at a conceptual level.
So that's in a nutshell the course
I want the readings and the order in
which you have to do them are listed on
the website.
So I'm not going to go through them.
It should be relatively self
explanatory.
I want you to read Chapter 15 of the
Black Swan.
And the reason I want you to read that
is because it questions the validity of
the standard normal distribution model
that psychometrics is predicated on and
wilcock a lot more about that later.
But I think you need to know it because
you're going to learn in psychology that
most things are normally distributed.
And all of the statistics that you'll
use in psychology are predicated on the
idea that they're normal distribution
holds.
But there's lots of situations in which
it doesn't hold and they're important.
So for example,
money is not normally distributed,
right?
1% of the population has 50% of the
money.
And then if you take that 1% and you
take the top 1% of that,
then they have 50% of all the money that
the top 1% has.
And lots of phenomena like that.
Artistic productivity is like that.
Anything that people create productively
is like that.
So,
okay,
exams,
you can look this up on the website.
Here's what you have to do.
There are three exams,
they're not cumulative.
There's one 15% essay of 750 words and
the online exercise and it's pass fail
because you know,
I don't know how I'm going to grade you
for your virtues of your faults.
You know,
that's your problem,
but you,
you know,
so all we'll do is check to see that
you've actually gone through the
exercise and half intelligible manner.
So,
alright,
now I want to start with
that so you can write it down if you
didn't.
But here's a couple of things I want to
tell you.
Um,
I have some insight into my own
personality.
I'm very industrious,
I'm not very orderly and a very high in
openness.
And so I'm telling you that because
there are some things you should
consider if you want to take this course
and you should really consider them
because not every course is for
everyone.
If you're unbelievably organized person,
this is not the course for you.
Okay?
Because there's a contradiction between
openness and orderliness.
And the thing about orderliness is that
orderliness puts everything into boxes
and the boxes are tight and the
dichotomies are black and white.
And I'm not criticizing that.
There's great utility in orderliness,
but orderliness,
fights with openness.
And I like to break boxes apart.
And so if you're the sort of person who
is orderly,
we're like really orderly.
You'll know this.
How clean is your room,
like is have you alphabetized your soup
cans?
If you have,
then this is not the course for you,
you to to take this course.
There's two things that have to
characterize you.
One is you have to be willing to read.
Okay.
The reading load is quite,
I don't think it's overwhelmingly heavy,
but the material is quite difficult and
there is a,
there is plenty of it.
So if you,
if that interest you like don't take the
course.
And the second thing is,
you know,
if you're the sort of person who
spontaneously talks about ideas with
your friends,
you know when you find conversations
about things that aren't related to
ideas,
somewhat tedious,
then this is the course for you because
it's,
it's really because I'm an open person.
I can't help but make my course.
I can't help but created in that image.
I'm really interested in ideas.
Like I tried to tell you why it's
necessary to know them because an idea
is an interesting to me,
unless it has utility for you.
But we're going to go all over,
and if,
if,
if you want a road that's defined and
like a single track towards a goal that
isn't this road,
this road is going like this.
Like you just heard,
you know,
you just had a lecture,
so you know what they're going to be
like.
So you're welcome to be here.
I'm thrilled to be able to teach you
this material,
but don't say I didn't warn you.
All right,
well that's that.
So we'll see you Thursday.
Bye.